look around a little bit up and down the
street please
yes go ahead
go back to the school okay so we're
going back to the school
which side of the school was that do you
think our mantra JJ there is a hill
shown the school you see that hill right
there could it be like where the s is
pushing right there there's the hillside
down down I'm thinking is I'm thinking
it's an extra to the school do you think
it's up in that area
all right
there's another couple over there
can we go due south that looked like the
area that you saw JJ
okay we're not see any evidence of that
I'm just a again please
well I I don't I don't see any activity
on that side of the hill why would they
be doing it over there chat but he's
orbiting come back he's right over the
area we're looking at man it this just
seems to me like where we have the most
activity
their notice
worthy all the officers I saw a moment
ago
there's a hole right there wonder if
they put that's where they put the cheer
guys it doesn't look like they're
thinking somebody's gonna come out of
there
okay go back to the campus for me would
you pushing right there on those
officers
look around a little bit more
keep coming around yeah
yes we are Santa Cruz fold right here
our fresh jars
let's go to the let's go to that area
they had taped off right there
now come down where the tape is there's
some officers there go to the right good
tilt up
all right tilt up there you go follow up
the tape follow our own shape
this is a good spot I'm happy with it
this hole here please
what would you call that area mean you
guys I mean it's not a capture it's just
like a logical yeah what do you call it
where everybody goes what now
what would you call that area it looks
like that's where the shooting occurred
there's some covered benches you can see
all the backpacks up there I mean a
courtyard or something I'm just a quad
I'm really a card been a while since
I've been in school
it's like quad like that qu ad quad
what does that stand for do you know
all right open up wide for me let's look
around but I want to be able to come
back to this if they come to me because
I want to talk about that area let's
push into the front see if we can see
anybody being treated any students
anything I'm not a parents out front
okay keep looking around for me give me
a little wider shot of the whole school
for a moment let's go back to that area
where we were before where they were
searching no not there the the hillside
goes down to the right yeah I'm good any
time I think it was down to the right
where they were all congregating the
officers yeah I'm good whatever you want
to go I don't see them out there anymore
hun the hillside okay and they cleared
those okay best shot I think is that
quad or that courtyard or anything like
this is fine too
we'll just move around as they come to
us
are those students okay
let's just keep looking around a bit
pretty static right there
okay they're good they're leaving that
gets a good shine and they're just
walking out
all right pretty much you come back to
me we'll talk about the courtyard the
card will just move around
show me the front of the school looks
like they're leaving and then there's
look around to see if we can find more
ambulances are coming in they may think
some of the kids are traumatized I guess
there's more injuries than they have
initially reported give me a wide shot
and the tuber you see any any more kids
being moved that's a good stuff
yeah good what
there you go that's a good shot
I'm saying the kids okay yeah good goes
to marches good
apply a little bit to the west place
good eat yep
yeah Leslie I'm Philip so we've been
watching the authorities clear all of
the classrooms and then they're taking
the students all to the auditorium here
it looks like they must believe that
there's not a shooter on campus or they
wouldn't let the children walk like this
since a children but the the students
walk like this to the auditorium to
gather I want to go to the right though
and in this quad area where the students
come together you can see some backpacks
up on that area underneath the trees and
it appears to me that's where the
shooting happened I say that because
it's been taped off we had a lot of fire
department personnel paramedics there
first responders in that area initially
and then they have now since left but
that's the area it looks like they've
cordoned off with the tape the crime
scene tape they're trying to keep people
away from so they can comb through that
for evidence you can see a lot of
firefighters are still here on scene
we're seeing more ambulances arrive that
could be because they want to make sure
they have enough personnel here to treat
any of the students that are having some
sort of traumatic traumatic event
because of this the stress if you will
but you can tell the the large response
out front of course the crisis
counselors will come to try and ease
some of the tension of the students that
have to have gone through this the
campus itself has calmed down quite a
bit compared to what we saw we first
responded now we did see a search up on
the hillside where we heard that some
tear gas was shot into a possible
drainage ditch that they thought the
suspect may be hiding in that didn't pan
out they're also searching along Bouquet
Canyon and the riverbed there's a park
to the south it looks like they set up a
command post there so you know as you
mentioned such a sad day and you know at
least at this point though it looks like
the initial threat at this school has
passed because we wouldn't see this type
of posture if they hadn't believed
they've cleared the surrounding area
just the fact that we saw the students
walking casually towards an area
together so we're gonna keep you up to
keep looking around but there's an
active search probably a four mile
radius from here about if two miles to
the west was a home that was initially
reported on Sycamore Creek Road that
could be the home of the suspect they
were searching that area
so a lot of the surface streets are shut
down trying to get in here you just
can't they're really trying to lock down
this area and see if they can't locate
the suspect as quickly as possible
let's go try the house again we're gonna
go try the house again guys you okay
with that
let's go try the house again
I thought I didn't think it was there at
all where you look open up it's off Seco
Canyon Road so it's its way up to the
top of your screen way up in there yeah
it's right it's gonna be right in there
no on the other side of psycho Canyon
Road right that major psycho Canyon I
believe go go to the right pop your
screen push in up up on the other side
of psycho Canyon Seco to open your
picture please open up your picture
psycho Canyon is the north-south streets
of major these sacred Echo Canyon on the
left side of your screen it's on the
left side of that remember right close
to it push go to the right there you go
come down towards us because that's
where they initially responded and then
they were searching down here when we
loved
yeah they all seem to be looking at this
outs are behind this house there's a
couple officers on the bottom of our
screen as well
there's not much of a hillside there's
that little ravine right there open up a
little wider why oh oh there you go
there's some officers up there
right now I noticed that - I don't know
what to tell you man there are problem
of the camera chat
it's the focus issue let's look on the
back of the house again can we go a
little bit further to the east and leave
we can peek down in there because
there's some officers up on that hill
deputies
okay they're looking at that house hold
it right here that appears to be the
house that they're looking at is that
one right there open up let me see
officers in the front or they are they
yeah that one okay that looks like the
one let's just keep our eye on the back
all right
I think we're okay here are we okay here
are you worried if we're too tight
studio open up a little bit open up a
little bit just to play it safe yeah
you better open up
go back to the right and I don't want to
show it - can I show that studio can I
show that house or not and the officers
I need some direction somebody give me
some direction on that go to the right
go to the right yeah well we're gonna
push in on this home here I real
concerned with what we're doing is would
you push in and go to the right a little
bit with the camera you pushing right
there that's fine this is where the
officers initially responded this home
right here we have the address on
Sycamore Creek what they're doing now
about four houses to the south of this
is all west of cycle Canyon Road is
surrounding a home officers behind the
home officers in front of that home my
concern is if the suspects inside
watching us he will see the location of
those deputies and we just cannot give
that away what they've done those
they've completely surrounded it they
have deputies hiding behind their
vehicles with their guns drawn at that
home in questioning they also have
deputies behind the house or using
ladders to go from one home to the next
so they could peek into the backyard of
the house in question on Sycamore Creek
Drive so in situations like this you
know you get a report that somebody
spots a suspect matches the description
of this individual they respond this
could be happening in several different
areas you know about a search on Bouquet
Canyon and the riverbed and but this one
seems to be the most prevalent the most
activity is here on Sycamore Sycamore
Creek Drive I'm just really hesitant to
give away the position of the officer so
hopefully you understand the rationale
behind that but there's an active search
right here it appears that the deputies
LA County Sheriff Deputies do believe a
suspect may be in one of these homes so
if you live in this area I know you put
this information out already but keep
your doors and windows locked they
certainly don't know where the suspect
is they have some idea possibly but you
know a lot of times they respond to a
situation and it's not the individual so
the suspect could be anywhere in this
area so just keep that in mind
there you see the SWAT team the armored
SWAT vehicle coming in that is so
effective so they go right up to that
house in question once again I just
didn't want to show that activity
because it may give away their positions
but this is an area they're really
devoting a lot of their
tenshun so the suspect could actually be
here in this home or behind the home on
Sycamore Creek Drive
exactly now the demeanor is that they
believe there's someone in that home in
question who could be the suspect
you know significantly different than
what we saw at the school when people
were walking around the home in question
is again this is Sycamore Creek Drive
it's west of Seco Canyon is about six or
seven houses to the left which is south
and they have that's where the armored
vehicle went right to the front of that
home and they have surrounded that home
not only in the front with deputies
behind their vehicles with the guns
drawn but in the back there's a hillside
they have deputies up on the hill the
two adjacent homes they have they have
walls that separate the homes they've
used ladders so that they can get you
know SWAT team officers up and they can
get a good look into the back yard in
the back of the house so they're
diverting all of their attention on that
one home in this area it must be their
belief at this point time you see the LA
County Sheriff's helicopter flying
through that the suspect is in that
particular home you can tell only five
or six homes a north of that where we're
looking right now it's very casual there
are people walking around but remember
folks if you live in this area you have
to have heard the helicopters fly by
I've seen a lot of times officers have
responded they believe that someone may
be in the home the suspect and he's not
so that means he could be anywhere we
don't know for certain that that
individual that has been on the shooting
rampage is in that home if he is in the
home they're going to get him into
custody will not get away that that is
reserved
yeah specially on this stretch I think
officers have already gone to all these
homes right here in this particular area
and said hey Stan
we
[Music]
do we not have a signal
I'm looking at Oh we're go ahead climb
but I mean we're 3,200 feet for her high
as Oh
it's our picture live anybody are we
live studio let's go back and look at
the home please real quick
making orbit so you can climb let's go
to 3,500 feet if that helps I don't lose
a signal
well that guy walked awful awfully
nonchalantly
to the front of the house yeah the guns
are pointed at him is that an officer
right there or not they must have
cleared this house
basically right up to the front door so
I'm not too sure this is gonna be this
spot this case you hear something else
that they respond to
there you go push into those officers
there top of your screen top there along
side of the house to the right to the
right stop push in
or he's not in the house exactly I agree
with you
but there's no way they would enter a
house like this as they thought a man
with a gun was inside
yep
you somebody give me some direction down
there can I show this or not
I just have them searching at this this
home but I'm trying to get direction
from the studio
[Music]
yeah
to keep the orbit coming around [ __ ]
back up in the front
go ahead JJ
okay
let me know if you get any more
information about him not being a threat
obviously I can't report that at this
time I wouldn't think nice doghouse back
be careful here because if they come to
me real quickly probably out of pole
hold it right here open up a little more
this 9fx is Santa credo with our 40
all right I think it's safe to say Santa
Clarita it's a mile west of the school
okay
good push in it not too much activity I
think I saw something to the right go to
the right right down in there
push in it looks like most of their
attention is that home or you just go
back and look I think they were gonna go
in the window they're about ready to
going that side window yeah it looks
like they went in it look like they've
entered the home they were taking down
the blinds when we were looking at it a
moment ago so that looks like this is
where they believe he is
yeah they're walking around like there's
no concern any longer here so this is a
we can show this now I think because
they don't seem to be care
I think this he's either not in the home
Rees but he's been shot
and he's dead would be my guess
so if you come back to me studio I can
talk about this we're ready to go what
are you looking at
better hide than love
teller
[Music]
there's some officers on the top of your
screen we could show anything we want
now there's no way that they're worried
about this guy I don't think he was in
the house it didn't bring him out and
[Music]
go back towards our house
all right
[Music]
I mean I live
I'm in
[Music]
I got you hi amber
okay sounds good
three minutes and break
[Music]
one two three one two three one
you wanna [ __ ] yes definitely
[Music]
but lives are dangerous back
Oh
[Music]
I'm so happy
ready ready
[Music]
[Applause]